okay so let's get started so in this uh
session before lunch we'll have uh two
talks one here and one from far away uh
so Mika has come from far away uh to
tell us about open problems that have
baffled Tony
so far I guess so I think that so far is
probably important yes
um okay hello all
um so I was really racking my brain
about what to talk about in in this kind
of non-standard meeting
um so I thought it's an excellent
opportunity to take stock of my PhD with
Tony and like revisit some of the things
that uh were left over things we didn't
solve our failures if you want
um so I sat down I tried to thought what
were the things we really wanted to
prove we couldn't and I couldn't really
come up with many problems and it's not
like we solved everything we ever wanted
it's more I think it's a feature of the
mind that it kind of blocks uh traumatic
experiences
um so uh so lucky I found this like an
old
document of open problems so I haven't
touched this for like five years and
already like I'm flooded with uh
traumatic experiences so
so there's one incident here
um where we uh we thought we had a
exponential lower bar for cutting planes
against Titan because with Toady
and I guess Robert and Noah also in the
room
um just you know we had a manuscript
ready but just days before submission we
realized that there's a massive hole at
the very foundation of the proof it's
incorrigible and turns out yes you
probably know this is not even true it's
like there are upper bounds surprising
upper bounds that were found by other
researchers the next year so the upper
bars are actually best paper at CCC so
we failed
um
but okay so the loads over props I can
only talk about a few of them so I
decided I'll choose um a kind of a theme
um which I had a lot during my PhD which
was a kind of an interplay between the
structural complexity Theory and
concrete complexity
so here's a picture of from one of my
papers on
structural relationships in
communication complexity it's a kind of
an intimidating diagram
but just wait for a few slides and oh
I'll find you even more
um so so the general idea is that we
have our fantastic uh classical turing
machine complexity classes
um we can't really separate anything but
what you can do is you can study there
like circuit analogs or query complexity
analogs which are usually done for the
purposes of giving at least Oracle
separations between the classes
it's a general template
um and I want to kind of show a few open
problems uh from this perspective so of
course Oracle separation is like a
classical hobby uh from the 70s so let's
see what we can still do about this uh
today
so let me kind of explain this
correspondence between jury Mission
classes and this uh query analogs so
maybe the most the simplest
correspondence is just okay P stands for
uh polynomial type of compute
efficiently in the land of query
complexity and circuits we take this to
mean
um shallow decision tree so let's say an
in-bit Boolean function it's like
efficiently computable deterministically
if there's a poly log and depth
a decision tree for it
um so that's like the first
correspondence you could do it for any
class you uh choose to pick so maybe BPP
gives you randomized decision trees NP
corresponds to Long width DNS so if you
have a Boolean function that admits a
low width dnf it's like the yes inputs
have made short certificates that
they're uh yes inputs
you can go up the polynomial hierarchy
so
um the second level for example would
correspond to uh death three circuits
with an or gate at the top and I suppose
polylog Fanning at the bottom
so these are kind of circuit models we
can prove more abouts for the concrete
models of computation
another way of defining them if you want
is to you can just fix a complete
problem so for NP for example the
complete problem would just be the or
function on n Bits And um you could ask
like which Boolean functions reduce to
Computing or on the shallow decision
tree reductions so you could ask what
what class of functions can I compute as
an or a bunch of shallow decision trees
okay that's exactly low with dnfs is is
the model
um okay so these are all like classical
correspondences we can have you know
been doing this for
ever so are there any kind of Separation
questions that are open uh
um
about these like basic uh circuit models
how would we hope I could go about
finding open Oracle separation problems
so one way of doing this let's see is to
go on complexity Zoo there's a
complexity Zoo diagram here
um
uh if I
perhaps a little bit so here it's a very
useful like active diagram you can keep
on classes and see what's known about
them uh here I've highlighted in
particular one plus zpp to the NP
it's another class below it called s2pf
or symmetric alternation probably very
few people have heard about this but
this diagram is saying
the STP class is great means we don't
know whether this class is contained in
this one there's an inclusion one way we
don't know of an inclusion in another
way
um so this was actually one of the
things we um
uh did studies okay this inclusion in
one way is an old result uh a
non-trivial one and it begs the question
like can you separate these two classes
in the other direction relative to an
oracle
um I'm actually going to define the
classes too much that are a little bit
esoteric but you know we're naive grad
students so it seems interesting
and so back in Toronto I was uh Monday
discussing this question with Tom Watson
uh who was a postdoc at the time he
collaborated with a lot
um so you can imagine the scene like in
the Toronto Theory lab uh we'll hunch
over this this whiteboard and I actually
do help you a little bit I didn't look
like this back then so that's a lie it's
more like this so
um
your hand
and uh we consulted with Tony about this
question I don't know if Tony remembers
this at all but I certainly do
so Tony said uh I don't think you want
to hear this do you do you remember what
you said
yeah so you said am I really remember I
think you will solve it but I don't
think you should spend time on this
stuff like not important enough
um
so with the hindsight of like eight
years you can report that like both of
these are false in the sense and I still
haven't solved it and uh I'm still uh
wasting time on this and um and it's
even worse not only am I wasting time
but I'm like asking people uh
um in fact I'm doing it right now so I
still hear about an approach to this
problem you know the approach is almost
more interesting than the application so
um
I think that's a payoff at the end
um so my Approach by the way so
it's not just a random or a possibility
people do care about it there's a recent
survey of a few like remaining Oracle
separations you could hope to still
preview the modification of the
techniques we have so Lance Fortner has
a survey and then he does mention this
very problem
um but okay let me tell you like an
approach to this it's a it's a circuit
complexity puzzle I want you to solve so
there's a very old uh Oracle suppression
result by Center showing that you can't
do something called approximate counting
in the the second level of the
polynomial hearty so Sigma 2p
um so it's a circuit lower Bond what
does it actually say in
in detail
um so it says that you need exponential
size step 3 circuits for the following
problems I should say it's important
that we're looking at an or gate at the
top and there's a polylog studied at the
bottom so these circuits should not be
able to do approximate counting of the
Hamming weight of the input so if I give
you an N bit string and you have to
distinguish between whether the
Hemingway is at least root n or at most
half rooted so there's like a constant
Factor Gap in these two cases it's a
partial promise problem
um and what's interesting about his
probe is that um
that it's approved using what's called a
top-down method so here's the debt three
circuit you want to improve a lower
Bound for us I promise there's an or
gate at the top
so you can think of the circuit or
of cnfs cnfs of low width
and Center shows this function you can
sort of start analyzing a hypothetical
debt three circuits from the top gate
and it's essentially you'll find a
contradiction uh further down that is
the circuit is too small you can't
compute this approximate counting
problem
foreign
so this sentence result is actually not
a very well known result I don't think
but it's very interesting because it's
one of the few circuit lower bounds for
which we don't have a bottom-up proof so
bottom up meaning you know starting to
analyze from the input so think of a
random restriction method so switching
lemons
uh so we lack such a proof and I think
It could only Supply me a bottom-up
proof of this old result
uh we've been business and that would
maybe solve the Oracle suppression
question so that's my question but I
actually have an even approach to uh
um a bottom-up proof so what do you have
to prove uh to get to bottom of proof so
I have a A variation of a switching
Lemma uh actually I advertise this just
a few weeks ago at dark stool so I call
it kind of call it our half switching
Lemma should be easy to prove maybe by
the end of the workshop please uh so let
me just first recall the quickly
what does a usual switching limit say so
if you start with um along with CNF and
you heat it with
a restriction so
um
I guess I'm looking at the Restriction
that leaves onset let's say some like
root n number of variables so the stars
are really like randomly chosen amongst
variables and then for the rest of the
variables you just put in zeros and ones
50 50.
so
switching lemon hostile says that if you
perform this restriction then you're
left with just a shallow decision tree
um okay so this is classical stuff
um I guess you know good fraction of us
has proved or used
such methods
what I wanna I wanna variation of this
now I say what happens actually if I
only half restricted so I I don't put in
both zeros and ones I just put in zeros
so still I choose some
root and variables to leave on set at
random but the remaining I set to zeros
so what happened this is this is my like
half restriction
so what happens what does the
what happens to the CNS
what kind of property does it gain from
the Restriction so actually let me ask
like what candidates for
such a property what do you think
happens to your CNF
especially people who I haven't asked
this before
so some candidates have like when I put
this to Avi because one day also Robles
just nothing happens uh you know you
didn't like uh have a random enough
restriction
but that's wrong something does happen
and I can prove it to you right now that
something happens
which is uh it's a kind of a trick like
What if I
further restrict the formula so now I
put in mostly ones and leave some
variables still on set
or the composition of these two types of
restriction is one of the things that
hostart has considered and we know under
that sort of restriction you do get a
shallow decision tree
so somehow
a property X could be
if I further restrict the formula I get
a salary that's an ugly property but
it's something
so I'm asking you again like something's
happening but give me like a good
semi property
um
something like syntactic about the the
function that's like not the cheating
property I just mentioned yes
so I put mostly zeros and I put mostly
ones and these are the types of
restrictions that horse start considered
to to prove lower bonds for these types
of functions
so maybe you know I don't do quite 50 50
ones and zeros but they're
um
I have some ideas what this property
could be
um actually ask this of hostard at the
workshop so here's one thing that like
um is my conjecture is that maybe the
properties that after the Restriction
the function you have is such that look
at its one certificate so like partial
assignments that Force the function to
be true then those certificates don't
feature many ones
if you think back like why this would
suffice to prove I give a bottom up
proof for this uh impossibility of
approximate counting because after you
restrict here the approximate counting
problem now asks you to sort of
distinguish between all ones versus half
ones
so
a structural property like this would
would give the
um
the thing I wanted and actually I think
this
switching limitations is more
interesting than the original
application uh itself like yeah this is
like the payoff you you get when you
explore very uh esoteric looking
questions so Tony can I have your
permission to work on it from this
[Music]
laughs
okay so that's open but it should not be
the people who do switching that much
maybe you can tell me how to do it
okay so that was maybe
you know one one line in my file
um let's browse a little bit more what
else do we have
um
15 minutes almost so let me uh let me
look at something else it's like in the
similar theme looking at uh low depth
circuits or low levels of the polynomial
hierarchy
okay in In classical
um complexity here we have this like two
big
you know for any complexity assets big
distinction am I looking at a class
that's syntactic or semantic so
um let's say syntactic by definition
means that the class has complete
problems so our usual class is B and B
um
so there are loads a little more there
are also interesting classes that don't
seem to have complete problems so it's
some somehow the definition of the class
involves some sort of a promise
um so maybe the most basic example is
just um bounded error probabilistic
polynomial time so there's some kind of
a promise that the randomized algorithm
produces the right answer with high
probability
so typically you see classes that have
some Randomness involved or maybe you
could have a version of npu that
guarantees a unique witness why do I
have a unique witness well that's sort
of a promise a semantic promise
also if you look at
intersections of syntactic classes you
could still result in a in a semantic
class
okay so this is a big divide amongst the
classes we study
and he's a kind of a
machine for producing conjectures in
concrete complexity
is you know suppose I look at a semantic
model one of these promise models but I
asked it to solve a total problem
somehow you know you could it seems like
you can't really use the power of this
semantic promise if you're the problem
I'm asking you to solve is total that
that's sort of the intuition and let me
just
show you this um
interplay kind of a few examples
so here I have at the top a semantic
class at the bottom a syntactic class in
fact I've chosen the highest class
for a semantic class I choose the
highest subset that's a syntactic class
and I generally conjecture that if you
look at now you know the query
complexity analogs
in the class of total Boolean functions
okay so this was characterized by
randomized decision trees but if I ask
if the computer complete problem you
should the power of the model should
somehow collapse down to the syntactic
class so In This Very example it's this
is a
you know classic I shouldn't say full
claw but like classic resulting query
complexities uh if a randomized decision
rates also total Boolean function can
actually convert into a deterministic um
decision traits okay maybe there's some
loss in
polynomial loss in the height of the
tree but
um that's allowed
so here's the
framework sort of in action we have
theorems like this yeah
I mean the one that you showed that
would be yeah
uh yeah I suppose I was too lazy to
track down the references it's it's
unfair to say it's folklore
here's another one
so I look at uh in Pages program
semantic loss I think the highest
subclass that syntactic the conjecture
is that the total Boolean functions this
should be a collapse so uh in this case
it's known like if you have a Boolean
function that I can write it both as a
kdnf and a kcma so there are short
certificates for both one and zero
inputs well then you actually do can
construct um
a shallow decision tree uh for the
function
okay so I mean I teach this in my
to my Master's students in my complexity
class
okay so these are known results but like
we can look at any pair of semantic
syntactic classes so let me take this
and kind of ask the analysis question
one level higher up
so what if I look at the intersection of
the the second level of the polynomial
hierarchy what would be
a subclass of this
that's syntactic and sort of the highest
synthetic class you can come up with
say again
is correct so I mean you could go and
look at the complexity diagram to know
the highest uh
I think technically plus you can find
okay so what does this this pattern mean
it suppose I have a total volume
function
and both that function and its
complements admit uh small debt three uh
circuit so or at the top and I I suppose
polylog padding at the bottom
so again now there's a new conjecture
if you're Computing a total Boolean
function it should collapse so that
function should admit also an efficient
what what is the got a circuit analog of
B to dnp I wonder if people know this
sorry second decision lists that's
that's right decision list
[Music]
um
so this is wide open uh and in some
sense it's a win-win situation so you
can prove this and that sort of
cohesively meshes with our intuitions
but maybe you could surprise me a show
this fails this fails because you can
identify
a topically a function you can compute
here efficiently but not here so that
would give you a new complexity class
a new syntactic complexity class whose
complete problem is the counter example
to this you found so you win either way
um
so this is a fun game we can do a little
bit more so here I've picked uh as my
semantic class
Arthur Merlin
and the syntactic NP so what are the
query complexity analogues I suppose
here it's just a randomized dnf so
probability distribution of a DNS and on
some input to sample a dnf and uh the
DNS should give you the right answer
with high probability
so my conjecture is that if you have
such an object and you're Computing a
total Boolean function well you should
just collapse again
um
down to just uh in this case a dnf
it's wide open uh in fact
exploring is connecting something that I
said before you could and we could
collapse would be you could start with
something in between there are semantic
classes in between in particular the
approximate counting problem I already
mentioned
so suppose I have a total Boolean
function efficiency is reducing the
approximate counting your approximate
counting had the promise that this
impacted Gap in the Hamming weight I I
conjecture you can't compute anything
more than just those functions that have
small dnfs this way
so make your approximate counting class
had this ruled n instead of constant n
so is there is a development
so so yeah you have to the threshold
should be some
polynomial into place
um you can't have any instead of routine
that would be PVP
remaining let me
browse a little bit more
um let's talk about actually not
necessary things but important problems
are important in the sense that Tony
would use the word
um so this is you know right at the kind
of the top of my list uh there are a
bunch of hard looking problems
I picked three here which I call the
Holy Trinity so these are asking to
prove dag like lower bounds uh which I
think we might now have a good chance
for because of these new lifting
theorems in fact the first question is
you're going to prove a better lifting
theorem with a gadget that's smaller
than is known like correctly we have it
for index Gadget not for in a product
as an application it would have
interesting consequences for
um like a breakthrough consequence for
improving law about resolution
and then at least in the proof
complexity workshop last week we heard a
lot about like wrestling people are uh
um like actively working on it other
than the old problem of proving monotone
circuit complexity lower points for
matching was probably proved quasi
polynomial should be exponential
so they're important problems but what I
like about them is that I think I've
tried all of them several years ago and
I feel like I get stuck because of the
same reason you know all of the problems
so I feel like if you solve one maybe
you solve all of them that's putting it
optimistically
um so let me just this is only for the
experts people who I've worked with
worked on lifting theorists but let me
sort of explain why I get stuck when I
uh try to prove these stack like lower
amounts
theorem for
uh the index Gadget and the way all
these lifting theorems work is you work
in you study communication protocols
then you want to analyze some rectangles
in the
uh communication Matrix so you have some
set of analysis inputs some set of box
inputs and you want to understand why is
this rectangle sort of query like
um and what we do is we say Okay large
rectangles may not be query like but you
can partition them into pieces each
piece is query like
and for the index Gadget we have a two
round protocol so Alice first partitions
per set and then Bob
partitions each of the remaining pieces
a bit further and we have this like the
main Lemma in this lifting theorems is
that you get a partition where most of
the pieces are query like what you want
but okay some PCS maybe become too small
and they're deemed error
and the the Crux like why these tagline
lifting theorem currently work is that
all the error pieces well they're small
but moreover they're easy to ignore
because they are contained in only few
rows or a few columns so if I want to
kind of delete my error pieces I just
ignore those two rows and columns and I
still like in a rectangular region
so this is what we did with I guess uh
well Dimitri is here well Tony has
proved lifting theorems for tree-like
models using the inner product gadgets
so what happens there why can't we do
this in the tank light case well the way
I see it is now the partitioning
algorithm is more complicated it's not
too round
Alice has to do some partition Bob has
to do partition and they go back and
forth so the partition is a bit more
complicated you still have the property
that at the end most PCS are query like
but there's some error pieces you have
to ignore and those error pieces they're
small
in measure
but as I've kind of drawn here
the problem is that they no longer
containing few rows and columns so they
the error said like form this kind of
block diagonal uh structure
and even though their measure is more I
don't know how to ignore them in the
argument I can't like get rid of them by
deleting few rows and columns
and I think this is the issue in all of
the three problems
um uh like if matching you can sort of
do a multi-round partitioning algorithm
this is the issue
um so yeah you can you can talk to me
about these things afterwards
but I I really feel like I'm I'm too old
for this already so I I like to give
this out for like the new Young
Generation maybe the vision has to
continue onwards
um so new young people or young
energetic old people uh like Tony
[Applause]
thank you uh that's great uh questions
comics
hi um thank you for your talk um so in
the quantum setting it's also known that
for total functions Quantum query
complexity and deterministic decision
tree complexity are polynomially related
so do you also have any conjectures in
the quantum section
so that's true it's one of those like
pqb is a semantic class so it kind of
should the total functions you should
collapse QP and it does sync in query
settings
um so that's sort of you know from my
framework that question is settled I
guess you could look at other Quantum
models to generate new conjectures so
there are these like Quantum analogs of
NP like qma
and yeah you can ask like you know what
what is the analogous query model and
how does it behave for total functions I
haven't looked at that
foreign
that captures the low complexity classes
do you think there's a
corresponding complexity theories for
higher classes
so I guess our like methods to prove
lower bounds start failing around P
space because the query or circuit
analog of P spaces uh you know massage
formulas and okay we can't prove lower
bounds for them all know about proving
under conditional lower bounds so my
kind of tools stop there
um and you know you would have to ask
other questions about the besides like
proving under conditional lower bounds
other questions
whether you removed
oh technique again okay thank you
because